[Music]
i've spent my lifetime telling people uh
that uh if they say how come you don't
you're not more buff i say irish guys we
don't really get beefed up we just don't
and then you come out and mock me with
your body
you're clearly a proof i mean we're
pretty much genetically the same person
only
you're uh
an incredible physical specimen and i'm
slowly dying what's
from another mother yeah
there you go well i mean first of all um
a bone to pick with you uh you're on
twitter you made a list of the hottest
gingers that's right in the world
number one you wrote sheamus
number two conan and number three seth
green and number four ron howard how did
you beat me
uh
some people may say it's kind of a
biased uh a biased uh you know top ten
or top top ten whatever but i felt that
you know being
a bit younger than you and more handsome
than you then i had to actually put
myself in number one now before you get
upset about that
so far i was just i'm being with you i i
i don't think i objected once i was just
going yeah yeah yeah i uh i did i did
your favorite putting in number two
though right that was pretty nice that
was that was okay right yeah seth
green's not happy that he's number three
but he'll have to deal with it no but
then he probably wouldn't come over that
desk right there so it's okay
don't mess with that man he'd probably
kick me in the knees for saying
you said when you wrestle that the worst
insult is you said uh that you once had
a fan hold up or sometimes you have a
family hold up a sign of your face with
my hair on it and that is the worst
insult to you in the world we actually
found a photograph
and what's so
sheamus
what's so wrong with that that's a good
look
the thing is i make that hairstyle look
good
there's obviously so many conan fans
here not many sheamus fans i couldn't
understand that
i'll tell you what though you're shocked
all these conan fans at conan
i'll tell you what though since we've
seen a picture of me with your hairstyle
i think uh the world would like to see
conan with the sheamus what do you think
yeah
[Applause]
if you don't don't mind here
it's like the the uh
viking bart simpson i was just
i was just expecting a photograph i
didn't know there'd be a style i wasn't
really sure this would happen either
okay good luck to you how's that
[Applause]
it's a work of progress it's a work in
progress
[Applause]
it has powers my friend it has powers
you know i'm you know we're fellow
gingers here we shouldn't really be
arguing we should be here we should be
cooperating here you should be arguing
about is who is paler that's what i want
to know
i think i actually i think you might i
think we're the two whitest people in
the world
probably you might actually be whiter
than me look at that look at that well
i'll tell you what the arms the arms get
a lot of stun there's another part of
your body you want to show off to show
off here that we can show that's why it
doesn't get any sun at all no how about
the belly no
i'm seeing my belly i don't give a [ __ ]
[Applause]
oh my god it's lighter i'm definitely
whiter what's it matter it's like it's
like two sons going supernova right next
to each other
i want to know is why we weren't uh why
we weren't asked to do twilight conan
that's what i wanted yes
uh yeah the makeup savings yeah yeah the
amount of money they'd save on that yeah
we should be playing the undead